mr speaker on windrush day we celebrate
all those who have made scotland in the
uk their home my party backs calls for a
major commemoration for the 75th
anniversary next year so we can properly
mark the value contribution that those
that came here have made
mr speaker this morning it was revealed
that uk inflation is now at a 40-year
high
families right across these islands are
seeing their income squeezed as prices
rise bills soar and tory cuts in tax
hikes hammerhold
after 12 years in government the tories
have left the uk economy in the doldrums
and pushed millions of people into
poverty
so can i ask the prime minister
does he think his government bears any
blame for the fact that the united
kingdom is doing so much worse than our
european neighbours
actually mr speakers i think the whole
house knows and the whole country knows
we've got a global inflationary problem
but this government has the uh the
fiscal firepower to deal with it uh mr
speaker and that is i think of benefit
to the whole of the united kingdom
including uh scotland as we've seen uh
throughout the uh pandemic and as i
think it's a matter of fact that taxes
are actually highest of all uh in
scotland
[Applause]
him blackfoot well well actually that is
that is not true mr speaker but of
course the prime minister the prime
minister can make all the excuses he
likes but the fact is the uk economy is
lagging behind on his watch actually if
he looks at france inflation is less
than six percent there this morning's
report from the resolution foundation
and the london school of economics is
the latest in a string of devastating
reports on the outlook for the uk
economy the report could not be clearer
the tory government's disastrous brexit
is driving wages down pushing inflation
and they'll make us further over the
next decade but instead of reversing
course the prime minister is recklessly
threatening a trade war at the worst
possible time will he finally come to
his senses and negotiate in economic
agreement with the eu or is it going to
willfully willfully push the uk into
recession here
uh mr speaker that nobody wants a a
trade war nor is there any need for one
but i think he's absolutely i'm afraid
he's underestimating what this country
is currently achieving not just the
modern investment but a record venture
capital investment in this country which
has now overtaken china mr speaker as a
venue for a venture capital investment
and not to say nothing of what we're
getting in tech and that of course mr
speaker the benefits of that are being
felt throughout the whole of the united
kingdom